joining us now on the programme once
again the justice secretary robert
buckland mr buckland great to have you
on this morning
um and of course big a day for you big a
big set of announcements which which we
will deal with in depth but
but i do want to start with that uh
oprah interview and
and harry and megan's accusations of of
racism
and indeed of bullying i'm just
wondering did you have you seen the
interview
no i haven't i'm afraid uh like many
people i was uh
busy last night dealing with other
matters work chiefly so i've not seen it
sure i i do wonder though whether or not
you feel that
that such is the nature of the
allegations particularly when it comes
to
megan's mental health the accusation of
racism
whether you feel that you know the
palace almost needs to respond to that
well i don't think it's right to me as a
member of the government to start
commenting about matters that are
uh for the royal family i i think it's a
long established precedent
i i really uh i'm not able to comment uh
i don't know about the
detail of it i've not seen the interview
and i don't think it would be right to
me
to uh add my foreplay to to these
matters
i i i understand the point because it is
a carbon copy of the point that was made
by the prime minister at the downing
street news conference yesterday he said
that he has a rule that he doesn't talk
about the royal family i mean
it's obvious that that rule if it exists
gets broken quite a lot he often
invokes their service he often invokes
their their patriotism
you know even on the matter around
prince andrew he said that you know that
the royal family is
beyond reproach i mean on that i mean do
you think that the royal family is
beyond reproach is that why
it is you don't feel it's appropriate
for you to comment
well i support the work of the queen and
the royal family their devotion to
public duty is well known the hard work
that they put in
every year even during their covet
crisis is well chronicled
i think that the queen epitomizes public
duty and public service
and we all look up to her and admire her
for that as we do other members of the
royal family who work
hard on that element of public duty
is at the heart of what makes the
monarchy work here in the united kingdom
uh well let's turn our attention very
directly to your own set of
responsibilities your own duties a big
day
for the ministry of justice uh tell us a
bit about the plans that you're
announcing
well we've got a major new bill today
that is a joint bill with the home
office so it covers a wide range
of new measures most notably on
sentencing i will be introducing
important changes to the sentencing are
for example of child killers
who will now uh be able to receive whole
life
orders under a life sentence we're going
to change the way we sentence
um children particularly with regard to
the most serious offense
of murder but also we're doing a range
of changes uh on issues like causing
death by dangerous driving increasing
the maximum to life and a new uh
extension of the offense of sexual
activity uh in position in abusive a
position of trust
covering people like sports coaches and
faith leaders which up to now have not
been in the same category
as teachers and social workers for
example so a wide range
of important measures that i know will
help to make our streets safer and
increase public confidence indeed and on
the latter of those the the the loophole
around sports coaches faith leaders i
mean the nspcc very firmly in your
corner they're delighted by all of this
but i suppose that some people will ask
well look there are perhaps another
couple of categories that that might
have been included
music teachers driving instructors could
you just explain the rationale for not
including those in this
yes well what we're going to do without
being too technical is uh
legislate immediately on sports coaches
and music teachers we'll have a power in
the bill to include
in the future other categories but we
need to make sure that the evidence
base is very clear there's there's
obvious concern about some of the
activities in those
other areas you talk about but remember
we're dealing with young people of the
age of 16 and 17
in many other respects of course they're
they're they're allowed to
uh have sexual relations even to get
married
and therefore this is a very sensitive
area and we need to make sure that
whilst
uh you know the abuse of power which
this is often sadly about
needs to be rooted out we've got to
maintain a balance between the uh you
know the rights of young people
and also the need to protect them from
harm and the bill also granting
new powers to break up disruptive
protests i mean two words spring
instantly to mind extinction
rebellion i mean this is a direct
response to the climate movement isn't
it
well it's a response to the fact that
whilst freedom of expression and the
right to protest
are at the heart of our civil liberties
we've got to think about the
sometimes huge inconvenience caused to
other people going about their lawful
business on these particular provisions
dealing with
uh the need to notify the police as to
the the time
during which uh the protest will take
place other measures relating to
ease of access to parliament which is a
fundamental democratic right of itself
and also issues relating to noise i
think get the balance right between
freedom of expression
and of course the the rights of other
people as well
who choose not to take part in these
events but who
often face great inconvenience and
sometimes
worse as a result of what happens there
is i think even by your own admission
there's quite a lot in this bill that
deals with
longer sentences for for particular
crimes
our longer sentence is going to change
anything is this all just all about the
the punitive
aspect of the judicial process i mean
the prisoners reform trust
says there's not a shed of evidence to
show that this runaway inflation their
words and punishment reduces crime i
mean is there
evidence that we will see a reduction in
crime well
i think the most obvious evidence is
that that if you incarcerate people who
commit offences
that are a danger to the public and a
threat to the public you're reducing
crime you're protecting the public and i
think one of the most important
functions
of our prison system is indeed public
protection and we need to emphasize that
but at the same time there's a whole
raft of initiatives that we're taking
with regards to uh rehabilitation of
offenders
so in in this bill for example i'm going
to be taking powers to extend
uh the use of curfews uh which i think
is a very effective way of dealing with
people in the community
and there are lots of non-legislative
initiatives i'm taking on mental
health on addiction as well to deal with
some of the root causes of offending and
to rehabilitate those
who are capable of change the sad truth
is
that there is a group of people in our
society who are genuinely bad
and who we need protection from and this
is what this bill seeks to address
um minister let's talk about it
responsibilities um
covered and blocked over 19 in prisons
in particular
can you just give us the kind of latest
statistics the latest figures that
you've had in terms of
how many cases how many fatalities we've
experienced in the prison system
yes well over the last year we've lost
just over 80 prisoners as a result
directly off covid
a number of about 20 or 25 others uh
died within 28 days of a positive covid
test
that out of a population over the year
of
140 000 people have been through the
prison
system whilst losing anybody is a very
difficult
and sad moment the work that's been done
by prison staff
and the authorities to bear down on
covet has been
important and remarkable the way in
which it was done by quarantining new
entrants and by really ramping up the
testing program which has happened to
great success
has helped us bear down on this disease
we've had to take measures to restrict
a lot of the activities of prisoners
we've been able to do more in this
lockdown than we did before
and we're learning all the time but the
story in prisons has been one of control
and once it has been very challenging
for staff
sorry sorry to interrupt minister but
we're running out of time but just just
in terms of the
the push from jcvi to perhaps allow
prisoners to be vaccinated on a prison
by prison basis you know they go in
they vaccinate everyone they come out
rather than the way in which it's
working at the moment
following the kind of the most
vulnerable categories just just explain
that decision i mean
a number of prison officers including
one of my acquaintances i've pointed out
that you know
what the prison officers told lbc they
felt they felt like lambs to the
slaughter
you know my friend said something a bit
more sweary than that
well i think it's important that we
absolutely uh
drive on with the priorities that the
jcvi
has set and as other ministers have said
it's important that we
adopt their advice and uh carry it
through
and i think that in large measure we're
already working through
uh the business staff who have fall
within the existing categories the next
categories of course will follow and
the joint committee on vaccinations and
immunizations didn't they recommend that
local vaccinations
teams should be should be given the
flexibility to deal with prisons in a
single goal not work down the list
well well i think the the important
point here is that
prisoners will not get priority ahead of
any other part of the community a number
of prisoners have of course been
vaccinated
because they fall into the most
vulnerable category and i think
following
uh the community is a sensible way to go
of course we'll always
listen to and look at the evidence very
carefully uh and my particular
priorities to make sure the business
staff get inoculated as quickly
as possible
the jcvi did recommend that local
vaccination teams
should be allowed to go into individual
prisons vaccinate everyone i mean that's
the case isn't it they did recommend
that
well i think where we are is that
there's been an interim report
there will be a final decision made
later this
month i think it's right that we've set
out the broad contours here of the
vaccination
program which has been so successful
thus far
and i will repeat that my priorities to
make sure the prison staff are
vaccinated
and that visitors shouldn't get ahead of
the queue
uh but should be inoculated or
vaccinated in accordance with
uh the the priorities set for the rest
of the community
but just on a related topic and still
regarding covet i mean the prison's
watchdog says that
prisoners and have been locked in their
jails for for more than
nine tenths of the day to keep them safe
from covet 19. i understand that there's
not an awful lot of sympathy for people
who find themselves in prison
but that isn't acceptable is it well i
think like
the rest of the community prisoners have
found that
the restrictions have been greater on
them than would be normally the case
in this particular lockdown there has
been opportunity to do
more activities so essential work has
been carried out and there have been
more
activities and educational opportunities
and of course we've increa
increased video and telephone
communication with families
as well i think prisoners understand the
need for
those restrictions and have accepted
that uh it's in their own interests that
they are kept
safe and we've worked very hard with
them to make sure that even though
the restrictions might be greater there
have been things for them to do and
occupy themselves
with very tough calls were made early on
in this pandemic but the results have
been
uh important and i think they are a
testament to the achievement of staff
and indeed the prisoners themselves
in making sure that establishments once
we've seen outbreaks
have not resulted in the sort of
fatalities that could have been the case
had those corrective steps not been
taken